hey there welcome to another version of
the Friday review now we promised Lea we
would do a sound check today and instead
we totally got drunk so let's do a sound
check right now wait oh you should be
seeing levels that are about a half inch
below the red zone on the audio meter
are you seeing anything it's too high -
I am too hot you can speak to that
so probably well I almost jumped out -
that was like oh no I just did that to
screw with you but okay
what okay are we over there now you
should be adjusting the main volume rate
or not this was actually live you can
tell oh yeah come on yeah you know what
the hell yeah exactly
here we go alright so what to do when
you have an extra zoom line around all
right welcome back to the Friday review
of games I as always am Ian nee Lewis
I'm Dan Galpin as they sign underneath
me says so and not as always it was no
surprise to me what the hell alright so
today we are drinking something
reasonably special this is uh something
that I have no idea how to pronounce
tricare maybe sounds good track we are
no certainly not that this is a handmade
ale brewed in the ancient brew house of
the oldest inhabited house in Scotland
so it's to a not particularly reputable
source it is one of the rarest beer in
the world actually I think that of the
reputable source was a dude in San Jose
California not Scottish
oh alright sorry nice hat though thank
you thank you I know this is this does
not actually fit the crazy hat standard
that I have been saying like oh if you
could mind opening this for me alright
so today we have five games that we were
looking at all of these
fortunately do run on our testbed device
here
is as always the transformer prize who's
transformed prime say TMI standby
exactly and yes and that does the cool
thing about it is they have a really
cool HDMI feature so we we like that
when we're actually trying to put this
on the air for you guys and for these
were actually nominated by you out there
in the audience and we did throw in one
additional one as a wild-card just
because I really like it but before we
get to our games we need to talk a
little bit about changes coming to the
Friday review the my gonna stop wearing
hats no okay
although I don't know what your hat
budget is but it must be gargantuan it's
almost as big as the beer budget but not
you know I'm actually buying this beer
myself now are you really yeah if you
want to try to chip in and know you
stopped expensing it okay you know
anyway yeah anyway we'll go into that
later so here's what we're doing you
know we we've gotten a lot of comments
asking you know what is it about the
votes is abouting suck or do you do you
even look at what we vote for and if you
do look at what we vote for aren't you
being just biased by people who have a
lot of friends etc etc lots of friends
apparently not okay based on based on
the number of votes people are getting
no developers have no friends at all
okay just one I don't want to clear that
up because most the game developers I
know work a lot so you know I was you
know outside of their local team I guess
if they have a large team
no no because they hate those other guys
they're always screwing with their code
right exactly anyway here's the deal we
thought it would be a lot more
interesting if we sort of broke things
up a bit and instead of having one
master list of everything to vote for
we're going to actually have a different
list for every week and every week we're
gonna pick a theme now next week's theme
is tower defense games so you know I'm
gonna be playing this stuff because I'm
a huge tower defense fan after that we
have driving games and then on August
10th we're going to be talking about
Asian RPGs so JRPGs K RPGs any you know
that stuff that you used to play on your
PSP
yeah not nominate those really soon
because that's got a while to get into
and
be cool if we actually get a chance to
play in them for more than a couple of
hours so let's so if you go to the old
moderator link you'll now see each of
those categories and all of them are
open and you can vote on any of them but
the voting closes the Wednesday before
the Friday that we're gonna review them
so next week on the 25th you're going to
be or until the 25th you're gonna be
able to vote on the tower defense games
that you'd like us to review on the 27th
and you know this is a dangerous week I
think the other good thing about this is
that we've made this the shortest week
so we'll be playing the least amount of
time because I tend to find that tower
defense games really do suck away all of
my free time rather impressively so oh
yeah yeah if you if you watch the review
last week you know that radiant defense
basically became my life for a great
deal of June and May yeah I'm finally
finally kicked that habit but it took a
while I had to go into Betty Ford for a
bit perhaps but exactly but we are
events now we can focus on our other bad
habits so we're gonna nominate some
games to use I'm definitely gonna
nominate Sentinel 3 and tower defense
absolutely yeah no there's there are so
many good games in this category I'm
tempted to actually give guns and guns
and glory or another another look
through not really I got to go um wait
I'm blanking on it alright okay I'll get
into other games later Oh
so alright so let's this let's go
actually to what we're going to be doing
here today which is looking at five
games now I'm gonna start off by looking
at aura Lux and the reason why is
because it's the first in the order of
icons it's actually on the screen which
is I think you went to alphabetically I
did yeah it's okay this is your wide
wildcard choice right this is my
wildcard Tori's also I just wanted to
give a give a call out the live
wallpaper that is actually on the screen
is actually being generated by one of
our five games as weeks oh my goodness
really so that is good live well it's
not bad I said yeah you know we keep
doing people if you want a great live
wallpaper you you should totally do an
aquarium map because people love
aquarium live wallpaper
but quite honestly a lot of the aquarium
apps out there
did you like wallpapers there duck
graphically impressive no no this is
this one yeah it's ones it's a nice one
so what we'll talk about this later when
we get into looking at fish farm let's
talk about oral X so aura Lux is a is a
is a real-time strategy game and yeah I
remember now now the developers showed
us this when when was it it was it a
conference or something it was a GDC and
it was it was a few months ago and and I
looked at it I had you without actually
having a chance to play it I was like
yeah it's kind of cool-looking but of
course you actually start playing and
you realize that it's actually very very
cool and this is I like to consider sort
of a preview of what's to come because
currently the game is only available on
Tegra devices and only available I
believe even on tablets but he is
rapidly adding our developers rapidly
adding more devices so and the gameplay
is fairly straightforward it actually
uses a control scheme that if you've
played the game Osmos you'll be familiar
with so use two fingers in order to
scroll around you can pinch zoom and
then I can actually go and I can take
individual ones and my little guys draw
around them with a circle and I want to
send them on to somewhere else I'll send
them here like that and will send to
something other than they'd they just go
just like like little mosquitoes exactly
exactly and what's cool about the game
there's a lot of them that I think
that's why they they've restricted it to
certain number of devices and I'm trying
to make sure that they've got the CPU
power too and I can also I can also send
them into my own star and this upgrades
the power of that star the number of
rings around the star actually
determines how upgradable it is you're
like sacrificing your dudes for more
power I would say that they're actually
becoming part of the fabric of the star
so they're colonizing that star as well
as I've added icing your dudes just like
some bosses they've had yeah yeah that's
true not like our boss though you would
never do that no not at all so so so
actually no we should show that we
should give a shout-out to our boss
Billy Rutledge who earned an honorable
mention as best manager of the year here
at Google
yeah why an honorable mention because
the
wouldn't let him get first place I think
I think I think the good news about
being an honorable mention is that he
gets the summit claim but he doesn't
have to actually do any work like the
people who actually afford the award
that like the people who are to get the
award have so but anyways a good shout
out to him around that and so this is
the game um one of the funny things
about this game is you can't accelerate
time but you have to buy it in the store
which i think is kind of Awesome oh
that's an interesting yeah you know we
talked a lot about monetization
strategies last week this isn't my
favorite one and the reason is that I
don't feel like I'm getting a lot for
for my money it feels like I'm I I think
that for me personally I like to buy
things that I feel like they took effort
okay if the developer mitt like we
talked about radiant radiant defense and
their additional packs well you know
those are simple things you could you
can make an argument that those packs
should have been included with the
original game but they contained extra
units extra weapon types extra
animations extra strategy all of these
things took time to design create
program and balance
mm-hm so I feel like I paid two bucks or
three bucks or five bucks for something
that people worked on when I'm buying
time I don't know it doesn't feel the
same way now I think there's a lot of
people who will pay for things like that
and certainly you know I'm going to talk
because I pumped plenty of quarters into
arcade machines I mean in my youth but
when you when you're buying something
that doesn't have an obvious labor
associated with it you're definitely
going to be attracting a different
demographic now the other thing you
can't really tell him unfortunately we
can't play sound here but although
strangely enough the music in this game
a lot of it is creative commons-licensed
but try getting the man to understand
what are we talking about here not our
boss right so so in any case the so you
but but actually a lot of these flashes
and pulses in my world
not getting completely obliterated it
happens yeah I just got attacked by the
green guys I'm basically screwed the
green guys and red guys are both gonna
go after my world now you guys out is
what happened yeah so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna get these guys out of there
because by getting them out of there
they'll attack each other and so that's
another good strategy in the game now so
the game actually plays music and in
line to the pulses and there's actually
sort of a beat going on there is sort of
a synthase shaaa kind of the season
scene fcj yeah kind of thing going on
thank you cool yeah so that's actually
that's actually kind of a fun part of
the game that you can fortunately you're
missing out on so that's an example of
the kind of strategy that one might use
unfortunately I'm kind of weak to be
using any strategy right now the other
thing I would would want to point out
here is that the game actually does not
do a bunch of things correct with the
back key and so developer already knows
this per figure you know the back key
whoa should should dome you're gone okay
to the game I think I might've hit the
HOME key there what what is cool about
the game is then you have a resume right
here at the beginning because I done ice
but you know what's not nice is that
splash screen so basically oh if I hit a
button that I didn't mean to hit boom I
gotta wait and watch your logo for about
well no that's relaunch it but
admittedly yeah the splash screen does
really show me yeah yeah if I can go
back it's not it's not it's not okay
it's alright admittedly it doesn't need
to be there the game's already running
it's already actually running in the in
other case potentially although
technically if you hit the back key to
exit it's the process so you expect when
you go back into it it's gonna do
whatever it does when you start so yeah
one of the things were it sort of mixed
but you can certainly multitask quite
effectively with it and I love the fact
that they put a resume here I mean this
is this is this is exactly what I would
like to see it makes very clear look
there's a game unless it's right there
at the front screen oh yeah sorry it's a
I don't want to break the HDMI cable
break the HDMI connection okay that's
weird we have better HDMI connections
this show is brought to you by doctor
HDMI that's right
alright so so that's that's Ora Lux
again there's there's a lot of really
great stuff in this game and and I
really enjoy playing it yeah so and it
runs great on the transformer prime so
we'll probably take another look at that
when they actually get to build out
maybe for a minute or two on it found a
future show
we're excited about this good stuff now
before we move to the next game let me
just ask you what do you think this beer
ah you know it's funny I uh I like it
yeah but I it's different it doesn't it
didn't like strike me as being no it's
good what's your opinion we should have
rate Oh taste it he has an accent oh
that's a good point there you go right
Oh Rachel why don't you introduce
yourselves to the guy here you can you
can picture in picture of yourself now
oh no you got the the Hangout deal
exactly i I found that a British /
Australian accent is absolutely the best
game review accent in the world all
right so let's uh let's take a look at
our next yeah no I'm not gonna look at
crates on deck because crates on dev
deck required yes cuz great time deck
requires rotating this let's let's go to
the ones that all work in landscape
first so I look at drive with zombies
and drive with zombies is a perfect
example of a game that kind of works on
tablets and what I mean is that a lot of
the touch areas are actually your size
in a way that's really really
appropriate no hang on hang up it's been
welcomed afterwards that's our account
right yes so it actually uses account
manager under so cool yeah exactly
exactly right yeah so now we use you
know select our vehicle and the goal
with this game is to avoid zombies you
know if you can't run you mean I feel
the tail but looking at it the graphics
are kind of low res and you get actually
into the game not bad no I well the
title screen I liked but yeah this one
it sort of reminds me of Desert Bus
mm-hmm
so you got you've got some choices you
can run over zombies now you see there's
a little icon there on the side I wants
me to shoot that zombie and trying to
roll and so for the most part
the big the biggest problem with this
game is that is is probably that it's
actually looking at this device as an
mdpi device rather than as a tablet
device what you really really you think
that's the problem
yeah so why do you think that's a
problem because the resources are really
small uh uh you're talking about the
size like up in the left hand corner
yeah exactly so there's okay so my
suspicion is that is it like in Scout
small that little arrow is on the right
so my feeling is it is it on a phone all
these would be fine I didn't have time
to play this on the phone so I actually
don't know so I think the real problem
in this game is there's like this great
concept but it could be ten times more
awesome yeah it just it really part of
it would be just actually going back and
doing a you know a demolition style
version you know some crash physics yeah
what's hicking what second where you
just have to crash everything in an
intersection we looked at it a while
back oh yeah yeah yeah I'm I don't
remember but I know where that game for
the Xbox 360
burnout yeah right there's a burner I
can't remember anyway okay right right
yeah exactly
yep and now when when I hit a bus there
I'd like something to happen I'm just
saying mm-hmm I think it would be cool
yeah and so you know you'll see you know
a lot of a lot of things in this game
are are there's a lot of the graphics
are just a little bit low register which
means certainly low res for a Galaxy
Nexus for a lot of that's just kind of
note about the game the numbers aren't
actually centered like we actually take
a look here I guess I'm not touching it
I thought that was this other sort of
avant-garde no no no it's it's actually
it's it's throughout the yeah yeah yeah
it's right throughout the entire app so
the main lesson here is tests on modes
of multiple devices and you know one of
the reasons that we that we do this show
is because we're kind of good friends
with the people that do game reviews for
Google Play and you know here's a tip
Google Play the Google Play game review
team the people that decide which games
get featured or not care a lot now this
may come
surprise they care a lot about the Nexus
7 all right now what we're looking at
here is essentially identical to the
Nexus 7 it's a little bit different but
the the hardware and the screen
resolution are are pretty much exactly
the same the DPI is a little different
if you're not working on this class of
tablet it's very very unlikely that
you'll get featured and the reason is we
as Google and especially the Google Play
guys care a lot about the success of the
Nexus 7 we're super if you watched our
show last week we know that we're care
about also I'm really excited about this
but you know we care about all our great
children really right I mean you know
and and the point is special place in
our hurt well yeah absolutely
most good mostly because it's really fun
to game on but um but know better yeah
if you're know if you're on this tablet
if you work on this town you know Asus
Transformer Prime a Galaxy Tab but you
know all of those things you have to
work on that class of device if you want
to be featured sure yeah I mean I think
I think everyone should make sure their
app looks good on a 10 inch tablet a 7
inch tablet on and a 5 inch phone unless
you're some or 4 to 5 inch phone unless
there's some really really strong reason
why your app you know doesn't make sense
and even then probably make it look good
anyways because even if it doesn't make
sense someone's gonna want to play with
it even if you're out your primary
reason is doing is doing 100 mile an
hour for photography with the phone
strapped to your head make it run on a
tablet okay
so awesome now let's drop your head I
know exactly so not only that it also
works as a deflector so um so in any
case um it's like it's like that at that
iPad you know YouTube video where they
should give the iPad to the grandfather
and then anything uses it as a chopping
block ah you know so uh so in any case
drive with zombies yeah so mostly I want
to see a lot I want to see higher
resolution textures I want to see the
control just being a lot more solid you
know the way the control is sort of it
feels like semi analog but not really
like you have to tilt in room moving and
and I really want to have much much
tighter control where if I if I tilt it
a little bit I get a little bit of
accelerometer rather than kind of a jolt
as if I've now pushed the left arrow key
that's sort of what it felt like when I
was playing the game
no one tip that
so we actually had a really fun summit
meeting with a bunch of all the leading
game engines and hardware manufacturers
right before Google i/o and one of the
things that came up was the fact that
very few games are correctly using the
gravity sensor now that's understandable
because that's a you know we've improved
it recently and it wasn't that good
earlier but if you use the gravity
sensor a gives you a quaternion loop see
now it's fun because we're doing the
game review and I can say quaternion
without having to explain what it is an
86 by anyways okay well a quaternion is
like a rotation matrix good enough good
enough so the the thing is it gives you
back a quaternion that you can plug
directly into your engine it's really
precise especially compared to the other
sensors it it it yeah it brings together
all of the data from all of the sensors
on the device to try and distill it into
the most precise sensor you can get and
it's not only is it precise it reacts
really fast so people that have used the
gravity center and I think you know
vector unit was there and they switched
over to the gravity sensor just a couple
days later and they're like wow we can't
believe how awesome it is to play
Riptide with this now now that we've
switched over but it just feels so much
better and it was pretty awesome to play
Riptide in the beginning let's just just
make that clear oh yeah wasn't a bad
game to be honest I was gay but it made
it even better
you know what yeah I've just cited yeah
that I hate the bags under my eyes oh
okay all right
no no we need to make sure that one of
these ones with the sunglasses actually
is the one that's used to the preview
frame on YouTube yes that's just that's
just the way it should be all right
let's go to the next game so the next
game I want this because if we combine
the two reacts we actually need to come
in wearing Blues Brothers outfits at
some point I think I do have a Jake mask
that I work for Halloween the other I
think I think I think just a suit with a
hat would work you know with the black
time yeah so um
bandit case all right
so the next guy wanted to look at was
Nosferatu Nosferatu is in the
endless-runner class and and it says
Nosferatu run for the Sun and actually
that the big the biggest problem with
this game is actually its market listing
page which has probably one oh yeah
let's bend that up this is yeah I don't
know a problem is that you don't see the
feature graphic on the tablet I guess I
could go into chrome dude don't you know
no it doesn't show up that's the problem
oh we're going to Chrome them yeah we
can go into Chrome see all right yeah
let me let me let schnitz wall I'm going
into Chrome let's cut this something
else so what but however this game is
this game is really fun and I thought I
hit chrome on here do I not actually
have chrome on it as a browser I think I
know I know
all right well let's go to play dot
google.com Stan is now using the
keyboard yes you can meet you give it
you you could be the voice I'm dancing
dan is now using this amazing attachment
which someone said was totally
irrelevant on tablets but it's actually
quite useful so I'm very good perfect
this is this alright now we're putting
it like the camera now let's go to knows
there ah - now I can't guarantee nose
candy for me it was kind of Awesome
you know whose candy this is what it
says let's do a game so here we are in
Nosferatu run from the Sun so yeah so -
look - look at this this game that was
the feature graphic now I do love the
inclusion of the Google Play logo as if
we didn't know we weren't already on
Google Play that yeah that's a serious
issue not not because we don't love
Google Play because of course we do and
props to you guys for representing but
it doesn't belong in your future
graphics because we can't actually put
this on the featured page we'd look kind
of silly yeah yeah so and the second
thing is obviously your text is really
really small you know no one's gonna see
no one's going to really be able to read
that if it
does get featured yeah the important
thing is you take this you back up about
20 25 feet from your average size
monitor and if you can still read your
text boom
you're good exactly because the thing is
we will shrink that down until it's
about an inch wide
hmm and that's an inch wide being held
you know probably about 18 inches away
from someone's face on a phone eye and
you've got to have some pretty good eyes
to read run from the Sun off of that
graphic when it's that size yeah I mean
you know run from the Sun is is useful
because it actually tells you what the
game is which is a runner so let's go
back to the game itself well and it
distinguishes you from all the other
Nosferatu titles out yes right the
weight I'm not sure we have enough we
need some more so just this is a one
control endless-runner I it is it yes it
actually I think might eventually get
more than one control but initially
that's your goal is is you one control
and basically you can you can do
different kinds of jumps oh yeah nice
are your ears actually acting as wings
in this case or is um well I should say
that there's um so what is interesting
is that there actually are two mode to
this game there is running and flying
and where did you eat that girl I think
so
okay I'm not positive oh I completed my
daily mission I'm sure I get some bonus
for that
oh and I've fallen and then I get fried
by the Sun that's really pretty though I
love I love the graphics on this I think
it's really really cute yeah it's really
well done I mean I was I was I was
really pleased with this I actually
played with the game a lot it there
isn't anything that I found that was
wrong other than again like like in this
particular case the back he doesn't do
anything yeah and but for the most part
by the way the biggest problem let me
just take one moment I want to pimp our
Google+ presentation or Google i/o
presentation okay and I did yeah we did
a presentation called 10 things every
game developer should know mm-hmm
and it was on yeah we wanted to another
okay so we weren't super happy with the
video team on it it was it was streamed
live or no one stream I was reported
there's a few slides that were super
funny that didn't make it on there but
the important thing is there's a lot of
really good information there and it's
not unentertaining and you get to see
what we look like when we're wearing
ugly cyan shirts exactly so and you know
when I'm not wearing my girdle which
really were that day as I recall I was
wearing your girdle I didn't know that I
never share a hotel with this guy you're
closing disappear and not the good
clothes here's the thing there are a
small number of things that a lot of
game developers get wrong we we
mentioned it on the show here but the
important thing is if you get these
things wrong you won't get featured on
Google Play and if you do them right
your chances of getting featured rise
astronomically because if you do them
right the first time you get to go to
the front of the line whereas all the
people that got them wrong go to the
back of the line so they get retested
basically of all these two if you do
something wrong even if people like your
game someone have to go you did
something wrong in your game is it
actually worth spending the time to
contact you is your game good enough
that it's worth fixing well if you get
everything right then the only question
is is it good enough to put on the
featured list on some day when perhaps
there aren't many things in the queue
then your chances of getting future too
much higher so definitely these are
really important things we're talking
about in this case the back key is
actually the biggest problem the game I
actually didn't see any other issues
with this game other than back key
doesn't play music on the lock screen
the game is fun the feature graphic does
need to change if we work in a feature
it and there's no question about that
but the game is cool and let's say ya
make some of those changes let us know
now I hope you've been watching and and
then we'll watch yeah we do like the
game where I definitely like the game
alright
alright so next game fish barn whoo now
fish farm is what you guys been watching
on the background if you've been
watching what's going on it and and I
would say there's anything you can't
really see from here the the tank is
slightly lower resolution that I want it
to be there's a little bit of
artifacting you can tell that it's
compressed but for the most part it
looks pretty good
and oh now hang on it's very a
scientific study hard to tell
yeah it's a it's a little blurry and you
can see here up in the corner you can
see actually yes and some some very nice
artifacting from on the background but
other than that it's pretty good my
feeling is if you're gonna have one
screen of your game that's as important
as this one in this particular case it
may make sense to upgrade the quality
just a little bit of that of that one
image so but what I do like about the
game is it has 3d fish which is so cool
it's very the fish are actually modeled
and as you can see they can spin in any
direction and they do it they do have
behaviors you can do stuff like I want
to I want it so first of all this is the
way the deccan minues work by the way is
I tap here there's this little plus sign
that brings up the actual menu and then
you can do things like feed the fish now
all of my fish are mostly full but you
can see that I can I can give them food
and the ones that haven't then are still
so they've got like RTS style meters
over them to tell them how much they've
been fed exactly the way this makes me
want to shoot them and the free I want
to spend my I want to send my Marines
out
so the food that the thing about the
food is that I the time I'm giving them
cheap food this food only lasts for
eight hours you can also get more
expensive food that will last longer and
some of it requires slow currency or
real money and some of it can be
purchased with in-game currency slow
currency right now it's a long time to
earn or the loss of course you're Dan
irate oh really quickly yeah so are
unless you just you know spend a dollar
or two on the game but sorry I'm no good
at semantics we really need to get Alex
back we do he did a receipt his fit to
this fit take when he was drinking the
beer that was on through a at guy
was pretty amazing and I wish we'd had
him on video last week you know I served
dan the 1000 I be you McKellar beer
which was quite bitter not impossible
bitter but pretty damn bitter um no
reaction I was extremely disappointed
yeah well yeah I wanted to find another
co-star at that I've been the problem is
is that I've been working with the inn
for a while and I've spent the last six
months building up a resistance to
bitter before the game and before I got
to try this one so you know it really
didn't mean much like ah better I'm used
to it
I really much but we drink a lot of IPAs
but when we fed that to Alex oh yeah it
was like a it was like a keystone ad
yeah that's because Alex shares just
keep with me so really you know it's not
so true yeah so so in any case but I'm
not bitter
he's the one who's bitter you say good
so I would why would I be better so can
we get anyone you know anything other
than these little fish though I mean
these no these are the starter fish now
if I want to you you red fish no show
you know so we can we can go to this we
can go edit fish first of all and I
select the fish here and I can make it
bigger you could just make the fish
bigger what kind of a bizarre eugenics
program are you well no no you see like
the problem is it takes a while so I can
rename it I can move it I can breed it
so or sell it there's not much I can do
but don't you have a news for hello and
then but I can go to the store and that
will say one and and if I go to the
store you'll see that I can buy this
fish or I or fur for slim currency and
get another boring fish so I don't so
until until we get put farther up the
list here with experience points and and
in-game currency I can't buy mostly cool
fish now this is one of the things I
noted about the game is this is a really
really slow slow scrolling one there I
don't know this is running out look at
your transformer time you're running on
a very fast machine and you're getting
terrible scroll performance now given
this is ICS and not jelly bean yeah no
ill something Bad's going here I'm
pretty sure the entire background is
being drawn as this thing is doing it so
first of all what I would do is Anna
given the given that this takes up
almost the full screen pause the screen
behind it there's no
reason to have that continuing to get on
they don't have it outfit out either
right this side yeah it's so you know so
I would I would say you know for the
couple millimeters of aquarium that we
got inside there
yeah totally not worth it no let's maybe
just make that a full screen yeah either
or just pause it behind it it doesn't
even have to draw you know it's so sad
watching that thing scroll so that is
that it that is a little one of the
unfortunate things that I noticed but
you know you can buy decor you can you
can get changed the size of your tank
which allows you to you can also buy new
tanks so you there's there's a lot of
stuff you can do and it's split between
currency that you did it that is against
low currency as well as currency that
you can get in the game that's by
officials by a cool dish I don't have
any cool right there's only one other
finish very cool fish what I don't have
enough experience points to buy a cool
fish give you some money no no I I can't
I have to actually get experience point
you have to play the game you can't even
just use money I can't go in here and
say let's just plop that look I got a
hundred bucks they don't I mean Google
has a hundred bucks I think my buddy
you know Armstrong has a hundred bucks
on his Google card and we're just gonna
buy a great fit actually gonna do that
uh not that I know of I think you have
to actually get it don't worry I like
that actually that's cool you actually
have to play the game so it's not just
my pony I also think kudos yeah so so in
any case in fact these fish I think may
are already bigger than when I first
purchased them I purchased I purchased a
new one just you can see what a new fish
would look like because well can we at
least get that gold tail thing well I
wanted to purchase one of these guys
here okay oh is it the little tiny one
there yeah yeah that one's smaller so
they do actually get in the air you're
an excellent fish keeper thank you yes
you can see my fish are all relatively
happy that being said I should I should
feed this new guy because you know mr.
fish than you are tomatoes hey I am the
gardener by the way he's one of those
guys that brings produce in and you're
like awesome it's bit today i pros -
yeah really you didn't get any of his
Cape gooseberries yeah you know the
French enjoy Cape gooseberry apparently
yeah so they're they're in anyways I had
those
I brought tomatoes are in the micro
kitchen today okay with the micro
kitchen yeah what you didn't like you
didn't give us first dibs on no I spin
the micro kitchen so but everybody goes
into the micro kitchen even people that
we hate well yeah so um so anyways
that's so um but this game does a lot of
things right one of them is actually has
a great list of settings here which also
is very slow to scroll but but that's
not a great list of settings because it
doesn't use the settings it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't use the settings you
know for a game it's better
it's true we do sort of give you a pass
when your game if yeah if you're trying
to fit into something but the truth is I
don't buying it here
you know well they're using standard
using standard controls but the other
thing well suddenly that they're not
using Hollow theme they've got that
they've got them they've got the menu of
shame they've got the zoom control of
shame fact let's see let's see then also
does it dies oh this doesn't feel like a
game settings menu this doesn't say okay
I I did something different from normal
settings that says I have a cool
artistic vision have it saying I I did
so what it's so much faster if I have it
stretched to fill the screen and low res
well yeah that does sort of make sense
right yeah of course I just I actually
but good but oh oh who does on their
part they actually changed correctly and
they don't crash which really that is
good but they probably shouldn't have
the the button of shame that's adding
Pat ability button of shame running out
there off they don't there the menu of
shame and a button but so it's just to
to kind of clarify what I was talking
about so obviously we have design
guidelines in Android we have things
that we want you to follow and that and
that applies to most apps and many you
know many things that aren't just normal
house yeah it most really we actually
have UI guidelines
yeah and that's and that's really
awesome now for games we usually give
them a pass because usually games are
trying to do their own thing they're
trying to like have this really cool
custom look this is not a cool custom
look it you'd be better off using our
yeah I mean there's a whole bunch of
Android controls sitting here that this
goes for apps as well like if you have a
very cool custom look of some kind and
we don't really care what it is but you
know if you've got some sort of art
direction where you
look you know we have our own special
look now one thing that we don't buy is
when people say we have our own special
look and then we boot it up and it looks
like somebody else's phone os we're not
buying that yeah what's up what's up
with that Wow but you've got your own
special artistic vision of course you
know do that we love that but if you're
not bringing anything to the table how
about just using our our normal controls
because people like that well these are
number controls but one said well it's a
normal setting a normal setting I always
hey what have any normal controls that
have that gradient part of yeah part of
the problem I'm sorry that would be I'm
no part of the problem with these
controls is it is that there are if you
look at it they are you as you know as
you can see the gingerbread version of
the controls and it would be so much
nicer do we ever ship that gradient uh
no but but these controls they even
wooden tipping really bad UI we never
went that far yeah so anyway so it'd be
nice to actually see these things themed
with the theme of the device and that's
very easy to fix and if you target SDK
version 14 it'll just happen
automatically so that's one thing I'd
love to see this game do could make all
the buttons or shame go away would
probably make this look a little bit
better even better is just use a
standard settings pane if you're gonna
make it low note on this much like the
RR stuff but not quite many ways I mean
did you have an intern that needed work
or what anyways so um you know I'm being
me and I apologize so but but one other
thing to note is I can be mean here is
because you guys have a great aquarium
it really looks nice we like it I have
one thing I would like to see is on when
you're actually on the live wallpaper
there's really not much feeling that I'm
sweeping swiping between veins it'd be
cool if the if it actually did something
you're already on you remove the camera
just slightly that would be awesome yeah
you're already rendering things kind of
in 3d and I know you've got this cool
like at this edge of the glass effect
blur thing going on the but actually
honestly I'd much rather see the screen
just move a couple of pixels as you did
that it would be more like a little one
something so that would be my only
complaint on the live wallpaper other
than that is really cool it actually
looks like an aquarium I kind of want to
keep it around maybe it'll stay
for a few weeks on this machine it seems
like someone else comes up with so one
more game to look at and I know hang on
handler um what happens if you like tap
the back of the screener now so that's
one other thing that you can do with
live wallpaper I want the fish to react
man yeah yeah make the fish react get
your get your taps actually do something
maybe maybe it takes you into the game
you know maybe maybe you tap on a fish
and it says do you want to feed it I
mean live wallpapers are very very
powerful you can do pretty much anything
you want in it and why not use it to
drive a little bit more user engagement
of course you don't want to you know go
overboard hey what's a little bit it
sounds good to me
alright final game is crates on deck and
this game has a distinct visual style
which which is fun although this title
screen is kinda cheeseball we just take
the keyboard off because damn that looks
kinda dumb yeah I know but we're not
we're not we're only showing the HD mine
for right now that's working for you
yeah I know I know go back to the screen
oh no no hor come Shane mr8 Oh so um so
crates on deck is a game that is in the
landscape mode by default play gravity
galleon which is the first series of
levels and so much cool as it tells you
which that you start off with that side
up when you'll see why that's important
because you rotating the screen actually
does change the physics does change so
we're up to rotate the screen to the
side now what we have to do is drag our
crates over to get that so you just
change the gravity yes
but the ocean is still in the same place
yes right no that's just a backdrop so
so the product is saying the world
doesn't make sense the world doesn't
make sense as much and also this game
doesn't make sense is what I'm saying
oh well that might be true but the world
definite doesn't make sense you know all
you have to do is see so what happened
in a movie theater this week and you
realize the world doesn't make sense too
soon okay
no I don't think I really I think it's
clear that doesn't make sense alright so
now what we can do is move is we can
drag these over and and of course I did
that completely wrong cuz yeah so
actually it sounds actually this is I
don't know I office level understand
what we're so whatever you need to get
the red crate on to the right yeah I see
if I drag the one underneath it physics
doesn't actually work they don't drag
together so I can drag it like that
we'll move the just frictionless cruise
they are they are frictionless crates so
I've got to get it all the way over
there so what I need to do is actually
move go like that and then go like this
thinking outside of the box so that's
the way the game actually works and each
one of the little puzzle and I think
it's really fun I think it's really
about and it's fun where you act at
where you have to deal with kind of two
things rotating the screen and moving
boxes oh sorry we lost two HDMI again
the whole reason for having this plugged
into the keyboard and looking lame as
you can see there you are is is so that
I wouldn't pull out the HDMI too
terribly often as they rotate it doesn't
help all that much but okay yeah exactly
it really doesn't yeah we need to have
like I would love to have an HDMI
connector that works like a BNC
connector yeah I would too I you know
that these all of these frictionless
kind of connectors are just so
everything that you're doing here seems
to be oriented around 90 degree
rotations is that yes you actually
rotated a different way no no just 90
degree rotations so I feel like wow
you're making me rotate my device but
which normally is not this painful on
most devices well but you know still I'm
you know I feel like a little bit of an
idiot doing it alright well only if
you've got this keyboard attached to it
like I do I mean realistically I mean I
I have to say I'm I'm a big fan of
things that that take advantage of
device rotation when it's a relatively
small rotation so I think driving games
for instance are make a lot of sense
other ones like I remember one of my
favorite games baguette you kind of like
you know rotate the device around a
little bit to shake your bag just make
all the contents settle well but when
it's rotating fully all the way around I
don't know that's it's a little bit
tough because they tell the truth I
usually play a lot of games with the
with our plugged in you know because all
a lot I'll sit in bed at night and I'm
charging my device and I know you know I
want to play a game or
you know you need some news or something
and and so I've got to keep one and it
kind of gets in the way if I'm doing
something yeah I like it I mean I think
I think that this is the kind of game
you play in the train only because the
kind of game you sit in bed necessarily
play you know it's it's really not a bed
game it's not a bad game it's not it's a
puzzle puzzle train it's like in a each
you want to solve each puzzle than the
you know reasonably small amount of time
and make the fewest number of moves and
rotations to do that and I think it's a
clever game I think they're in their
presentation is cool I would like to see
them you know even even though I think
that you know this this is kind of cool
I think that their crates on deck could
look a little bit the title screen here
could show that on the screen actually
oh yeah I don't know I mean yeah what
are you get a closer look here you got
that you have the shades on that just
makes things better it's true well okay
I mean this is not I I think that this
game it has a distinct artistic style
right right and it's it's not like the
most professional artistic style but
that may be intentional I'm sure that
that is intention I actually mostly wish
the logo it's longer sure I'm not sure
because because you got all this stuff
that's a little bit playful and then you
got drop shadows and I asked myself what
professional designer would have said
you know what crates on deck needs a
drop shadow I would have done that it's
true I only put a drop shadow there but
I'm not a professional designer yeah
yeah also also you know just having
having buttons at dead that don't that
don't actually react well you have a
button that doesn't do anything I guess
it does do something I just didn't I
couldn't tell it's just turning to
subtle colors okay so it is but but yeah
so there's there's a little bit of
polishing probably good could be down
here mm-hmm
so is there anything else we want to
talk about other than other than that
other than making sure that people know
you didn't tune in for the beginning
that we're gonna be changing the format
of this show yeah and so forth
format exactly why we're still gonna
drown out here even though I'm paying
for it now again isn't that's right and
that's the way we like things and also
so so most importantly we're gonna be
nominating different categories of games
so next week is going to be tower
defense games we got
our driving games then we got that our
J&K rpgs and you can vote for these now
you can vote for them all the way up to
the Wednesday before the day they get
reviewed absolutely and what you should
do is we would prefer that the developer
of the game nominate the game and we
would we definitely encourage you to add
a Google+ link to link to your own
Google+ profile don't just put your
Google+ name because a lot of those
names are duplicates we don't know
necessarily who you are you get the URL
of your Google+ profile and put it in
there then we'll be able to find you and
we'll let you know if your games being
reviewed or not and hopefully get you on
air with us live and have a bunch of fun
with you anyway that didn't come out
right but the other thing that we want
though and this is quite important this
please do make sure that you have the
Play Store link in your title don't make
us guess what it is
just you know link to it in the Play
Store link to your Google+ profile and
then anyone that likes it please vote it
up if you don't like it vote it down
either way our moderator page does allow
you to leave comments and we'd really
really appreciate it if you could leave
comments saying why you do or don't like
each particular game yeah like you know
it's enough to say this guy is not my
friend you know that least least that
explains your one-star vote you know it
so you know it's so-so but you know at
least put that in there very good that
was actually a song that I wrote back
when I had time to do such things it's
called lithium and you can't get it
anywhere but you know maybe all online
exactly so you know it you'll at least
get to hear a little bit of it if you
want to want hear it again you of course
there you can replay this when the live
stream goes window archive screen goes
up and so yeah that's another episode of
the Friday review game thanks for
joining us we will be back next week
when we review tower defense games
please visit our moderator and let us
know what you think we should review go
ahead and leave comments
on the YouTube stream when we decide
that we're good and drunk and we want to
hate ourselves some we will totally read
them absolutely either way we'll see you
next week thanks a lot